we are here with drew gooder jordan
james the creator and host of good deeds
buffalo a show dedicated to those who
give back and we were inspired by each
other i would really like to introduce
you to someone who like you stopped at
nothing to achieve his dreams please
welcome the founder and ceo of hawk
media eric huberman
[Applause]
good to see
meet you thank you yeah
eric um i'm so fascinated by your
company um and will you
talk to jordan um about what you do and
why you wanted to speak to him sure so
run a company called hawk media and we
help brands all over the world grow we
work with about 700 different brands and
i came in touch with your story and even
what you were just talking about and i
was touched and so drew reached out and
asked me to help mentor you and as well
as hawk media support you so we're going
to be spending time with you
working with you
going to be giving you a copy of my new
book the hawk method um
and then also
uh you've been through a lot and so we
want to give you fifteen thousand
dollars to help support what you're
doing
[Applause]
of course
of course
it's incredible
[Applause]
i don't know what to say besides thank
you so much
um thank you for believing in me thank
you everybody in buffalo for believing
in me
um
and
thank you mom
my mom's up there watching me right now
and i can feel her i can feel her
emotions and her power
so thank you
[Music]
i'm really excited also you know not
just money to go towards and support but
some guidance and some ideas we all need
some directions uh you know with
how to get our messages out there where
to put them i mean business is complex
and there's a lot of different avenues
of how to navigate all of this thank you
for allowing me this well eric i look
forward to your tutelage and your wisdom
and would like to spread that it's going
to be wonderful to have
somebody who has more experience than i
who i can go to i'm sure with questions
on how to do the best and thank you so
much my email it'll be great
and maximize and build and stay yes
[Music]